the village of azni Lies forlorn and in
Ruins
its mud brick stone and wood buildings
no match for Friday's earthquake
one of many such communities in the AL
house region close to the epicenter in
the southwest of Morocco
barely a structure remains untouched it
is here in the high Atlas Mountains that
the earthquake has been most devastating
and deadly
there are a lot of blocked roads a lot
of people can't find their parents and a
lot of people are still under the rubble
people are still searching for their
relatives everything went down on them
the mountains their homes you can't
really go through they are still
clearing the roads
as frantic efforts continue in a Race
Against Time to find survivors for some
it is too late
in the village of mule Ibrahim Hussein
Adney collects basic supplies for his
family in what remains of his home
nearby he recalls neighbors who did not
survive
they're still people buried here in this
house they didn't get the rescue they
needed so they died I rescued my
children and I'm trying to get covers
for them and anything to wear from the
house
funerals take place in the Searing late
summer heat
where necessary Mass graves are being
prepared
for Rescue and relief efforts this is a
challenging area to reach windy mountain
roads are strewn with Boulders in some
places made Impossible by Rock Falls
most Casualty that we we experience the
are in the mountain area and as you know
the mountain area is not very accessible
and people are living top in the
mountains the government are making
onion what it can to rescue the people
but but it is very difficult to reach to
reach out to them since the winter
season is about to start people have
lost their houses we need all supports
to be coordinated in order to have this
population amid criticism on social
media that the government should be
allowing more foreign Health in a formal
request for international assistance has
finally gone out more than 36 hours
later and experienced search and rescue
teams initially from Spain are on their
way complaints here too about the lack
of a formal government response to help
people living rough in City squares in
Marrakech
after a night sleeping in the open air
the stoicism of those who say that all
this was God's will he's turning to
anger
[Music]
a crowd protesting that the government
should be doing more to help them
the Century's Old Market city of
Marrakesh has been spared the worst of
This Disaster but here too in the
ancient Alleyways of the Medina homes
and shops are damaged lives and
livelihoods upended and tempers on edge
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera Marrakech the
World Health Organization says 300 000
people have been affected by the Quake
that'll require massive International
Aid efforts which are on their way to
Morocco our correspondent Stephanie
Decker has the details on a delivery
that's heading to Morocco from Qatar
we are at the aluded military Air Base
in Qatar where the
part of the search and rescue operation
happening we will take you inside
one of them to show you
what this kind of operation looked like
Qatar just one of many countries that
have pledged help
to Morocco in the aftermath of this
devastating earthquake vehicle Hardware
very much Essential when it comes to the
landscape in Morocco the most heavily
affected area the Atlas Mountains very
remote and very difficult to get here
which is why there is such a Race
Against Time when it comes to trying to
find survivors this is of course
crucial when it comes to the aftermath
of an earthquake other things being
flown in
tense medical equipment also search and
rescue equipment and a lot a lot of food
so again four planes being flown now
just 24 hours after that earthquake
happened around 50 Personnel search and
rescue men who will be on the ground in
that fight in the help to try and find
as many survivors as possible Stephanie
Decker Al Jazeera at Al ude Air Base in
Qatar